-Nous nous trouvons
à Boulevard Saint-Michel,
..dans la cave de la librairie 73,
..où les marionnettes siciliennes
nous donnent une représentation..
..de la vraie histoire
de Charlemagne et de ses paladins.
Charlemagne, c'est un grand
souvenirs pour vous, France Gall ?
-Oui, c'est un souvenir bon
mais très lointain aussi.
-Quand vous aviez choisi
cette 1re chanson,
..votre 1er succès,
surtout,
..pensiez-vous à la réussite
de Charlemagne ?
-Non, j'ai été très contre,
car c'était une chanson d'enfant.
Mes musiciens, les personnes
qui m'entouraient, me disaient :
.."Pourquoi tu fais cette chanson ?
Tu vas te ridiculiser,
"..c'est grotesque."
Au bout d'une semaine,
..le disque était sorti,
j'ai téléphoné à 3-4 h du matin..
..à mon imprésario, je lui ai dit :
"Arrêtez la sortie du disque,
"..je ne veux pas
que ce disque sorte."
-Parlons d'une marionnette
que vous avez rendu célèbre,
.."La poupée de cire,
poupée de son".
-Elle a été traduite
en 4 langues :
..allemand, italien,
anglais et japonais.
-Et vous parlez ces langues ?
-Non mais, par exemple, le japonais,
je l'apprenais par phonétique.
Mais je connais un peu l'anglais..
..et j'ai fais 3 ans
d'allemand au lycée.
-En Amérique,
on la chantait en français ?
-Je ne sais pas. Peut-être
qu'elle a été enregistrée..
..par quelqu'un d'autre
en américain.
-Vous venez de choisir une nouvelle
chanson "marionnette", également,
.."Polichinelle", est-ce que c'est
pour garder votre public d'enfant ?
-Pour ce disque,
..j'aurais voulu avoir
un disque plus adulte.
J'aurais un peu touché
des personnes un peu plus âgées,
..sans laisser tomber..
..mes publics jeunes.
Mais je voulais faire un disque
plus âgé, en définitive.